so this past weekend we saw drop
the interview between joe rogan and
kanye west
it was exactly what i expected and it
would be impossible to really dissect
what he said and you know everything
that was said in that interview
because it was it was truly a kind of
uh let's say kind of madness of words
and of images that that although
at the first glimpse looks like it was
all over the place and kind of wild
but when you look at it from a bird's
eye view all of a sudden
patterns appear and you start to see
what exactly was going on
and so that's mostly what i'm going to
try to do is try to take a bird's-eye
view of what
happened during that interview try to
see how he is really
manifesting the manner in which a kind
of folly or a kind of embodiment of
the fool has the capacity to flip things
around
and to bring back a kind of balance
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so yesterday on social media i posted a
quote
and i said quote beauty will save the
world unquote
kanye west on jorgen in 2020. now of
course kanye west
did not say that during the interview
directly but
there was an interesting process during
the entire interview
which was that kanye west would say
things for like 15 minutes and
and would draw these analogies and would
talk at different levels and would
bring about different examples and uh
then joe rogan would in
one sentence or in like two sentences
would say yeah
this you know this is what you're trying
to say and and kanye would look at him
and go yeah of course
um and so ultimately i would say that if
we could resume
everything that kanye west said in his
interview was was
that and of course that quote is a kind
of misquote taken from dostoevsky
uh from the uh the idiot in which the uh
the prince mishkin who is the idiot in
this that story
is asked is it true that you said uh
that beauty can save the world that
beauty will redeem the world
and the prince doesn't answer but this
of course has
become a trope in kind of orthodox
culture to talk about how beauty will
save the world
often people don't understand what it
means
but in this context in the context of
kanye i think we can understand
what it means or what it could mean
let's say
and so if we had to synthesize what
kanye basically was doing during that
interview he would circumambulate around
a point and so
joe rogan would ask a question and then
kanye would instead of answering the
question directly
would start to give different analogies
at different levels
and this is how we see the manner in
which kind of
how kanye west has something of a
symbolic perception or has
symbolic intuition which is that he
understands the world analogically he
understands that
once you have tapped into a certain
pattern of being
then it doesn't matter what you apply it
to
you know no matter what you apply it to
then it's going to work because you've
actually tapped into a true pattern
of being and if you had to resume
everything that kanye was saying it's
that seems to be
what he was saying and so a great
example in the interview is
when jorgen asks him uh if you were the
president
what would you do differently what would
you do differently and his example that
he gives
is he said i would redesign those suits
that is he watched the debate between
donald trump and joe biden and
he really didn't like the way they were
dressed and so he was saying i would
redesign the suit
kanye west uh what i understand is that
he even redesigned
the room in jorgens studio where he was
speaking
uh and before he gave the talk and so
this is really the understanding when i
say beauty will save the world
the way that kanye sees the world is
through design that is
he understands it not so much first of
all as
moral questions or moral quandary but
actually a manifestation of
pattern and a man a manifestation of
analogy between different realities
and so for him redesigning
a suit is the same as redesigning
a state and so it was really fascinating
because every time joe rogan would
ask him about something in politics he
would say
this is what i did in music the way that
i
write music or that i design shoes is
the manner in which i would be president
and at first glance you would think how
insane is that
and there is a kind of craziness to the
way that he was talking
but deep inside there was also these
amazing nuggets of truth
that would come out as he was speaking
and so as he's riffing on
fluoride and you know uh
the exam which was just amazing at the
example that all the different levels
that he kept bringing
bringing about but you could see that he
had this really this symbolic intuition
because
at some point he talked about how he
said
we are in the movie we are in the story
we are in the video game
life is the real story that is
the way that art manifests itself
is not actually entertainment and this
is something i've been hounding at you
guys
forever it is participative and this is
what i've been telling you that kanye
west's intuition
has been moving towards this is why he's
also created these sunday services while
he's why he's interested in design
why he's interested in technology why
he's interested in
creating sustainable communities he
talked about making a monastery he
talked about
all these things that he's involved in
is because
he basically understands art as
participative
he understands that art is
creating frames in which we exist and if
you
create analogies so if you redesign the
suit it will actually
affect the way that people behave and of
course we know that's true
when he says it right away when he says
i would redesign the suits you'd think
wow i can't believe he gives that
example but intuitively we understand
that
you know if if you could give extreme
examples like if the the presidential
candidates came out during the debate
you know wearing chains and spikes and
uh you know
had dyed their hair then no one would
take them seriously and so the idea that
there isn't an analogy between the
public discourse between the state and
the way
that the politician presents himself is
of course of course
that is true it's true that those two
things are analogous
and so but the way that kanye
understands it is at such a primal level
that for him it's all it's almost all
the same
and so if if you he has this intuition
about a pattern
then he could whether he applies it to a
rap song whether he applies it to
as he said ruling the free world then
then it's all the same and so there's
some deep intuition in what he was
saying
but at the same time i would say that in
the interview we really got this sense
of this character who on the one hand
is going in every direction so he's
completely scattered he he's
constantly going riffing off and he
talks about
uh giving a symphony but i would say
that in the context
i think that in the context of the
interview the symphony
happened in the relationship between
jorgen and kanye west that is
kanye needs something to it seems like
he needs something to focus
him and and so joe was pulling out let's
say the thread of all the symphonic
things that connie was saying um and i
think that maybe that's why kanye is so
good at design is because
when he speaks he kind of
circumambulates and he he's going all
over the place but if you're creating an
object like if you're making a shoe
if you're making something at some point
you have to synthesize that into
into something which holds in space and
so it
forces him to kind of focus his
analogical thinking down into the object
but when he's speaking
then he knows that it's very difficult
to think that he has a limit of time and
and uh of things he can say and so he
tends to just
jump up jump between all the different
levels different levels give an example
from star wars
then give an example you know from
politics from
rap music and then fashion all of this
uh
scenes maddening at the the first first
glance and in a way it is manning
uh ultimately there is something
frightening about
about someone who kind of goes off in
all these directions but there's also a
kind of energy
and there's also a kind of let's say
honesty that is difficult to deny you
know
one of the things that i that i noticed
about kanye west a long time ago is that
he was
capable of acknowledging his
contradictions
and so that's something which
maybe is part of his hismanic state
which is the capacity to recognize your
contradictions but it's also
a kind of lucidity which most people
don't have he was he's
he was capable of recognizing when he's
actually a hypocrite
and you know he has certain values and
then he does other things
and then i remember in an interview with
someone saying like aren't you a
hypocrite and you just said yes
yes i'm a hypocrite and you could see it
in this interview
he said some things which most people
would never say in public like
he he talks about how he's a christian
and he wants these christian values and
these
these christian christian values towards
sexuality towards all this
and then at the same time he's saying
that he still
has a problem with pornography and he
still watches pornography and so it was
like
this this capacity to be completely
honest
and in that honesty to embrace embrace
these contradictions you know the whole
time he kept saying
that on the one hand he brags about how
much money he has and then
right in the next sentence he says how
money is nothing and how money
has no value and that it's just a tool
but you can see that
he embr he kind of embraces that
contradiction which just to a certain
extent is dangerous because
that's what leads into a kind of
breakdown
but at the same time it also offers him
a certain amount of power because
there's nothing you can get on him
because he knows himself and he knows
he's both extremely prideful and
extremely arrogant
but he if you point out his foibles he
also
he's just like yeah of course these are
my weaknesses these are these are my
foibles and so
that those extremes are both kind of
exciting but they're frightening at the
same time and there's something
extremely frightening about some of the
things that he says of course
when you hear someone say something like
god calls me to be the leader of the
free world
you know the only reason why we don't
find it absolutely frightening is
because
there's something in kanye because he's
a rapper because he's uh
you know he's goofy in the way he acts
uh and the way that he
that he's acted in the past there's
something which because we can kind of
laugh at that
then it makes it okay but if anybody
else said
that he has a calling from god to be
leader of the free world
we would run away like at 100 miles an
hour from that person
you know and the idea also that that
you're going to redesign reality that
you're going to redesign the world
is a scary scary thought if if you take
it too seriously
but in his kind of contradictory
character
in his kind of because he
he manifested in these kind of strange
opposites and these strange
contradictions
it rather it rather makes us hope right
he says he believes in utopia he says he
believes in world peace and anybody who
says that should frighten you
seriously frighten you anybody who tells
you that he believes in world peace and
that he's the one who's going to bring
world peace
is really a dictator is a is a very very
dangerous person
but there's something about the way he
says it like i said the fact that he's
also willing to acknowledge his
weaknesses and that he's also kind of
circumambulating and he's throwing
things out and he's
he's he's all of a sudden says something
and then he stops and he says it in a
way that sounds like a rap and then he
says
i hope someone will i hope someone will
take that and put a b
to it you know there's some there's
something about the way that he speaks
which makes it less frightening because
in a certain manner
he's funny and so but nonetheless i
i would say if you have not watched this
interview it's definitely
worth watching it just to get a sense of
this idea of this kind of this kind of
fool character
who who is living in contradiction who
flips everything around
but then like i said he says it right
there in the interview he says
i tell the truth but in a world you know
i said
he said in a world full of lies that
truth sounds like craziness
that's exactly what i said about him you
know last year that's exactly what i
said about
the character of the fool is that when
the world is upside down
that's when the the fool appears as
someone who tells the truth
because it's almost in his nature to
want to flip things
and so and you can see all through he's
talking about he wants to change
everything he wants to
he runs to renew the world in every
manner which is frightening
but because the world is upside down
then he
to do it he ends up saying things that
are true and that at least we can pay
attention to in terms of the truth
there's some things that he said in that
interview
that no one else in the world is allowed
to say
what he said about abortion when he said
you know
uh also about
on the one hand talking about racial
conflict and
segregation and kind of racism that's in
american culture
but at the same time talking really
about how in order to trans what it
needs what you need to transcend that
and that success is what you need to
transcend it there's all these ways that
he's speaking that are very difficult to
that it would be very difficult for
other people to talk about
so if you haven't watched the interview
i would say it is
definitely worth it i had to watch it
twice or actually listen to it because
you know it's it's like three hours
right and i listen to it at like two or
like 1.5
especially the second time did the first
time i was like what's going on what's
going on i felt like i was on a carousel
ride
and that i was being spun around and of
course i expected that because that's
who he is and that's what
his role is but then on the second time
around then i was then able to perceive
the analogies that he was going through
and how he was he was constantly using
analogy
as the manner in which he approached
reality and helping
trying to communicate that if you grasp
the patterns
then it doesn't matter what you do like
if you have that intuition
then you can do anything and i felt some
resonance with what i'm trying to do as
well obviously on the smaller scale i'm
no kanye
but i would say that the sometimes when
people look at what i'm doing and they
look
at the fact that i'm making icons you
know i'm making reliquaries for the
for saints and making objects for
churches i made a
bishops crook for the the archbishop of
montreal but at the same time i'm making
comments on movies and on
on anime i'm you know i made a video a
video talking about video games
i'm also designing t-shirts and i'm
making comic book
but i'm also involved in the orthodox
arts journal and talking about sacred
art and sacred symbolism
and the bible and all that stuff and so
there's something about what he's saying
that i understand very deeply
because in what i'm doing but it's also
my perception
it has to do with the fact that the
pattern of reality
if you glimpse it if you understand it
if you have a perception of how things
work
then it doesn't matter what you're doing
they can be applied at any level
of the world of course in my case i'm
applying it more directly to art and so
trying to create let's say stories and
images
that appeal both to the most common or
the most popular level of reality
but that can also speak to the highest
aspects of their participation in the
life of the church
whereas for him he basically spans from
making shoes to making music to then
he he thinks that he can reorganize the
free world let's say
and so whether or not we think that he
can be able to do it there's something
about his intuition which is right and
something about the way he perceives
these patterns which is of course right
and something about his honesty
as well so those were just a few
thoughts about
the discussion between kanye and joe
rogan i'm sure there are many more
insights that one can get from what he's
saying
a mix of excitement and if you're
attentive
also a little bit of frightful things
and also
a kind of sense of this this spinning
and spinning which is somehow
nonetheless showing us some some golden
nuggets of truth which he's also saying
at the same time
and so i thank you for your attention
guys and i'll see you very soon
i hope you enjoyed this discussion on
kanye and joe rogan
as you know everything we do here on the
symbolic world is thanks to your support
so if you were like what i'm doing and
of course considering
that we're not on the good side of the
youtube algorithm
please go check out the
symbolicworld.com support to see how you
can support it
and you can also check out some of the
designs that i'm working on
including and of course particularly the
watch the full design
which was done in collaboration with
owen cyclops and if you don't know owen
you can check him out
on on twitter and i think he's on
instagram as well
people who support the work i'm doing
get an extra video a month
this month will be a continuation of an
interpretation of the story of sir
gawain and the green knight